madame monsieur bonsoir très importante
mobilisation des salariés de la sncf de
la ratp et d'air inter conséquence
directe et les perturbations ont affecté
tout le pays
le ministre de la justice demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur le
financement de son propre parti le cds
c'est une grande première vers 20h20
c'est bernard kouchner qui est ce soir
l'invité de carnets de campagne notre
émission de la campagne électorale
également dans ce journal l'inauguration
de la bibliothèque nationale de france
par françois mitterrand et l'appel du
pape aux catholiques un appel à la
désobéissance dans les pays où
l'avortement et l'euthanasie sont
autorisés par la loi
cela fait donc bien longtemps qu'un
appel à la grève dans les transports
publics n'avaient été autant suivi sur
l'ensemble de la france en a compté en
moyenne un train sur quatre aujourd'hui
grève également dans les transports en
commun si vous n'habitez pas en région
parisienne regardez ce à quoi vous avez
échappé yannick letranchant et philippe
deslandes la traversée de paris
d'un pas décidé mais la marche à pied
aujourd'hui n'avait rien d'une sinécure
loin de là la promenade était forcé pour
cause de grève normalement je prends le
métro mais manière ferme et donc j'ai dû
prendre le bus mais si on va plus vite à
pied c'était un peu long mais parmi
quelques sourires parfois quelques
grimaces souvent il faut dire que la
tente dans les gares est à géométrie
variable
huit lignes de métro fermée un trafic
rer très perturbé les rames
les trains sont une denrée rare et ce
soir comme ce matin les mêmes patience
les mêmes un patient sur les quais
j'estime que comme usagers c'est déjà
décidé de faire la grève du ticket à
savoir que j'ai une carte de madère que
je ne compose ne règle pas tant qu'il
n'y aura pas rétablissement fiables sur
les lignes notre journée si on n'y va
pas c'est pas marrant pour 1 m
quelques-uns qui fasse la grève c'est
leur droit
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais qui
nous assure quand même quelques-uns
très peu de trains dont pas beaucoup de
métro non plus pour les autobus est un
peu mieux 30% du service était assuré
bah si ça me gêne un peu mais bon pour
un jour on peut un peu attendre quoi
c'est pas une catastrophe
files d'attentes très longues files
d'attentes aux stations de taxis burbure
et débrouillard tente alors le tout pour
le tout
l'auto stop alors tous les moyens sont
bons les plus sportifs n'ont pas froid
aux yeux ni aux jambes c'est comme sur
des roulettes pour les autres du courage
de la patience car la route est encore
longue pour rejoindre son foyer
seule consolation pas de gros
embouteillages en vue ce soir la
circulation est relativement fluide et
c'est tant mieux
cette sacrée journée finira donc bien
oui contrastant avec le ras-le-bol de
certains usagers la satisfaction
affichée par les syndicats leurs
revendications n'étaient pas les mêmes
la mobilisation est là étaient unanimes
laurent bailly non ce n'est pas le
nouveau slogan de la sncf
d'ailleurs sur les deux millions et demi
de voyageurs touchés par la grève
aujourd'hui
beaucoup ont pris la chose avec
philosophie personne ne prend de billets
puisque paraît-il que c'est même gratuit
alors c'est formidable cette grève a été
suivie par les trois quarts des
cheminots c'est la plus chaude depuis
celle de décembre 92
au mieux un train sur quatre a circulé
aujourd'hui en france certaines lignes
ont été carrément déserté les tgv n'ont
pas été épargnés et ça c'est une
première
partout les cheminots ont revendiqué sur
les salaires sur l'emploi et surtout
exprimé leur crainte de voir un jour la
sncf démanteler la question la plus
cruciale aujourd'hui qui est posée aux
cheminots c'est l'inquiétude concernant
leur avenir dans l'entreprise de service
public sncf puisque des projets au
concours à faire éclater la sncf en
trois entités
face à cette grogne la direction elle
cherche à calmer les esprits il n'y a
pas de morcellement dans l'usagé au
moins à l'échéance du compte un plan qui
est en cours de négociation actuellement
très pas dire au moins jusqu'en 2000 en
tout cas cette grèce dont le succès ce
soir incontestable ne s'achèvera que
demain matin à 8 heures à moins d'un
mois de l'élection présidentielle
elle démontre que la fièvre sociale ne
retombe pas dans les transports bien sûr
mais aussi à la poste chez renault comme
chez les éboueurs
sans oublier les entreprises du secteur
privé et inter n'a pas échappé au
mouvement un vol sur deux aujourd'hui et
des retards considérables notamment à
orly l'aéroport de paris où des dizaines
de grévistes sont descendus sur les
pistes pour bloquer les avions pascal
golomer et patrick voix
cela a beau être le troisième jour de
grève et la troisième grève du mois
certains passagers ont encore été
surpris ce matin on découvre en or li
l'annulation de leur vol soit france à
orly et je peux pas bouger à cause des
grèves c'est de la folie en france bon
voilà la grèce qu'elle pénalise
l'entreprise sur les ouvriers qui
défendent leur beefsteak mais quand elle
pénalise les hôtes ils nous prennent à
témoin
on n'est pas partie prenante un vol sur
deux assuré la direction affirme en
avoir affrêté la moitié grâce à les
avions d'autres compagnies c'est
d'ailleurs l'un de ses avions qu'un
millier de manifestants ont bloqué ce
matin sur les pistes sans incident les
manifestants venus une nouvelle fois
protesté contre la fusion programmée
entre air inter et les lignes
européennes d'air france
on veut bien que l'on très une nouvelle
compagnie c'est apparemment une bonne
idée mais cette compagnie doit être créé
avec air inter en respectant le statut
existant à travers
il suffirait d'ajouter europe boudard
inter on aurait une nouvelle compagnie
qui s'appellerait air inter europe et ça
ne changerait pas du tout le statut les
personnels
si des gens d'air france doivent venir
chez nous on travaillera avec mais il
faudra pas qu'on soit aligné sur les
gens d'air france il faudrait que les
gens d'air france ont aligné sur nos
conditions parce que nous avons un
savoir faire et aussi on peut être
complémentaire
autant d'arguments qu'ils présenteront
demain à leur pdg avant de rencontrer
lundi cette fois aux côtés de leurs
collègues d'air france le patron du
groupe christian blanc
ajoutez à cela le mouvement de grève à
la poste qui continue lui aussi
notamment en provence dans les bouches
du rhône et le var et dans le
département du loiret les candidats à la
présidentielle ont largement commenté
cette grève
pour jean marie le pen les
fonctionnaires ne sont pas les plus
malheureux
pour philippe de villiers la grève doit
être interdite dans les services publics
en situation de monopole
quant au candidat communiste robert hue
il exprime lui son soutien total aux
grévistes soutient également de lionel
jospin le candidat socialiste qui était
à belfort et il n'a pas été épargné lui
non plus par la grogne sociale
rencontre animée avec les ouvriers des
groupes alstom france arvois et pascal
stelletta vous n'êtes même pas pour les
1500 francs d'ailleurs vous dites même
pas on écoute et vous référer par un
modèle n'avait pas tout à fait été d'un
gouvernement
c'est donc une critique son gouvernement
c'est d'ailleurs le gouvernement de
gauche qui a bloqué les salaires on
s'est battus ici dans les cinq semaines
avec qui aller les cavs ont sorti les
budgets qu'alstom de belfort de
sympathisants de lutte ouvrière prennent
mieux elle chausse pas partout de ses
cendres au fond par le moteur de robert
sedra lien gémellaire donc c'est pas
clair les cours n'étaient pas claires
ici c'est un contact plus direct avec
les hommes et les femmes sont les hommes
qui sortent de ce site gec alsthom avec
la diversité des réactions alors au delà
de tel ou tel militants de lutte
ouvrière qui défend son point de vue je
crois que les réactions en règle
générale ils sont plutôt de la sympathie
plus tôt c'est sûr vous qu'on peut
compter pour nous défendre mais en même
temps quand vous étiez aux
responsabilités tout s'est pas bien
passé en quoi les privatisations sur ces
deux thèmes
les syndicalistes de bulles et de
peugeot avaient déjà interpellé le
candidat dans une campagne de terrain il
y a aussi des moments plus nous
dans son fief de belfort jean pierre
chevènement accueil lionel jospin
l'occasion de lui dire le soutien du
mouvement des citoyens
mais à montbéliard son passé de ministre
de l'éducation nationale a rattrapé le
candidat socialiste face à des parents
d'élèves mécontents
il a défendu l'égalité des chances un
autre vrai thème le terrain antoine
waechter le candidat écologiste affirme
avoir obtenu 560 promesses de signatures
il pourra donc se présenter à l'élection
un sondage de la sofres pour le figaro
magazine permet à jacques chirac de
passer en tête du classement des
personnalités de droite préférée des
français devant simone veil edouard
balladur qui est à égalité avec charles
pasqua
suivent philippe séguin et alain juppé
et le ministre des affaires étrangères à
qui notre confrère philippe harrouard
consacre un livre coécrit avec isabelle
dath alain juppé ou la tentation du
pouvoir aux éditions jean claude lattès
quant au parti communiste il publie lui
un nouveau mensuel regards la
transparence judiciaire souhaité par le
gouvernement dans les différentes
affaires de financement des partis
politiques a conduit aujourd'hui le
ministre de la justice pierre
méhaignerie a ordonné une enquête
préliminaire sur le financement du cds
un parti qui l'a présidée pendant 12 ans
c'est donc une grande première michel
field un ministre de la justice qui
ouvre une enquête préliminaire sur le
financement occulte de son propre parti
c'est une première pierre méhaignerie
l'a fait dit il par scrupule
par souci de transparence et de rigueur
parce que je crois qu'il faut apurer le
passé que tout ce qui est je dirais dans
l'ombre doit être remis dans la clarté
c'est le meilleur moyen de corriger les
erreurs du passé même lorsqu'elles sont
elles ont trait au fonctionnement d'un
parti avec qui serait d'une particulière
affection pierre méhaignerie n'aurait
peut-être pas demandé l'ouverture d'une
enquête s'il n'y avait eu il y a huit
jours les révélations du canard enchaîné
sur la caisse noire du cds en suisse
dans cette paisible banlieue
résidentielle de genève un expert
comptable discret henri albert jacques
recueillait les fonds versés aux cds par
de généreux donateurs
il faisait fructifier l'argent avant de
le réexpédier en france en tout 4 à 8
millions de francs selon les années est
ce que vous savez d'où venaient ces dons
non je ne sais pas je ne fais pas
informés
je les suis très tardivement parce que
la plupart des trésoriers feront tout
pour ne pas informer leur président et
les protéger grâce à l' enquête de la
brigade financière le ministre de la
justice pourront enfin tout savoir sur
l'obscur financement du parti qu'il a
dirigé pendant douze années et policiers
devront notamment cherché à déterminer
si le système a continué à fonctionner
après la loi de 90 sur le financement
des partis politiques par souci de
transparence toujours et si les faits ne
sont ni prescrit ni administré le
ministre de la justice pourra alors
peut-être décidé l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire
à calais c'est le maire communiste de la
ville et jean jacques bart qui a été
mise en examen pour trafic d'influencé
mise en examen également du directeur
général adjoint de la compagnie générale
des eaux jean dominique deschamps il a
été laissé en liberté il est une et une
mise en examen qui intervient dans une
affaire de fausses factures liées au
financement du parti communiste une
culture de la mort a envahi la société
contemporaine l'affirmation est signée
jean paul ii dans sa 11ème encyclique le
pape appelle les catholiques à la
désobéissance civile dans les pays où la
loi autorise l'avortement et
l'euthanasie une critique violente des
démocraties occidentales
mary pierce amitié et joseph baltique
l'âge ne le fait ni tremblé ni plier au
contraire jean paul ii en signant cette
encyclique condamne une fois de plus
très fermement l'avortement la
contraception l'euthanasie à propos de
la contraception pratique est pourtant
par la plupart des catholiques tout à
l'heure au cours d'une conférence de
presse à paris les évêques de france ont
justifié la position du pape la tendance
peut-être d'un certain de nos
contemporains à faire passer les
avantages matériels
les avantages économiques les le confort
avant l'accueil de la vie avant le
soutien de la vie naissante lui semble
une des premières choses d'autres
sociétés qu'il faut remettre en cause à
propos de l'avortement toutefois
condamner durement par le pape
nous évêques de france ont apporté une
nuance une tolérance fait qu'un enfant
soit conçu il ya là déjà le mystère de
la vie puisque notre propre ville nous
appartient pas
et donc on dit toujours non à
l'avortement on pourra pas tenir un
autre langage ce qui ne veut pas dire ne
pas venir au secours et en aide des
personnes qui ont traversé une telle
épreuve
or ce texte provoque ce soir une levée
de boucliers chez les catholiques
progressistes qui dénonce là une dérive
distille vers l'intégrisme confronté à
une hélice qu'il n'arrive pas dialoguer
avec la modernité qui n'arrive pas à
prendre en compte les acquis de la
laïcité et qui n'arrive pas à prendre en
compte surtout la liberté de conscience
de chacune des personnes qui organise sa
vie en son âme et conscience en fonction
des problèmes qui sont les siens
l'encyclique tous les évêques de france
ont reçu tous sauf un monseigneur
gaillot
le nouveau locataire de la rue du dragon
l'a découvert cet après midi à sa
lecture il a émis un regret j'aurais
aimé que le pape parle du sida parce
qu'au plan de la planète c'est
dramatique et il faudrait rappeler que
le sida j'ai mourir tant que gens et
qu'il faudrait rappeler que le
préservatif c'est le seul moyen efficace
qui soit connu aujourd'hui une
encyclique éminemment politique qui pour
certains restent trop loin de la vie
quotidienne fait simple un homme 7/11
ans cycliste de jean paul ii figurera
sans doute en bonne place dans la future
bibliothèque nationale de france
françois mitterrand
là il n'est oublié il y a deux heures
c'est le dernier des grands travaux de
son double septennat dans cette
bibliothèque entre 11 et 12 millions de
volumes seront disponibles
les salles de lecture que le président
de la république a parcouru pendant une
demi heure
jacques chirac mais aussi lionel jospin
vous l'avez vue étaient présents à cette
cérémonie
la bibliothèque n'ouvrira que vers la
fin 87 principal casse-tête pour les
responsables transférer plus de 10
millions de livres de l'actuelle
bibliothèque nationale rue richelieu à
paris jusqu'à la bibliothèque nationale
de france
le voyage se fera en camion enquête
parce qu'elle dit c'est bon et michel
levasseur
après l'inauguration du contenant il
faudra bien penser l'année prochaine au
déménagement du contenu et le contenu à
la bibliothèque nationale ce sont 10
millions de livres 350 mille titres de
périodiques 1 million de documents
audiovisuels un tel déménagement sera
une première en europe et le chef des
déménageurs c'est elle
suzanne jouglet ne s'occupe que de ça
depuis un an
sa mission est claire tout déménager ne
rien perdre ne rien abîmer et surtout ne
pas gêner les chercheurs le principe
majeur qui n'évite et d'immobiliser le
moins possible l'interruption de la
communication donc la latte charnière
c'est la date justement de l'ouverture
de tolbiac dans le mois qui précède est
seulement le mois nous l'espérons et
nous nous battons pour cela la
communication sera interrompue avant
elle a lieu ici dans les locaux nous
sommes à richelieu après elle aura lieu
à te guette tout cela commencera au
printemps 96 pour 18 mois
les conservateurs en profiteront pour
changer le mode de classement des
ouvrages
le déménagement est donc bien plus qu'un
simple transfert on a fait un
reclassement de ses collections nous
appelons ça dans votre jargon un
récolement de l'ensemble des millions et
millions de volumes qui sont stockées
ici finalement bas ce qui aurait pu être
à mal des biens sont peut venir un grand
bien pour l'ensemble des collections de
l'établissement et voilà où iront les
livres 200 km linéaires de rayonnages
sévèrement gardé le rêve grandeur nature
est informatisé des conservateurs du
troisième millénaire
pas de circonstances atténuantes pour
willy van coppenolle condamné cet après
midi par la cour d'assises du gard à la
prison à vie assortie d'une peine de
sûreté de 22 ans il avait enlevé et
assassiné un enfant de 11 ans puis violé
une semaine plus tard deux adolescents
et puis à caen une enquête se poursuit
trois jours après la découverte d'une
adolescente retrouvée morte noyée
les pieds et les mains liés dans sa
baignoire la police ne privilégie aucune
hypothèse
et puis à rochefort dans les charentes
maritimes l' immense frayeur des
habitants d'un quartier un avion de
chasse a explosé en vol et ses débris se
sont écrasés sur une maison de la ville
françois privat 11h30 ce matin un avion
de chasse de l'aéronavale explose au
dessus de rochefort sur mer alors qu'il
vient d'atteindre sa vitesse maximale
l'appareil s'écrase dans les marais le
pilote a eu le temps de s'éjecter et
s'en tire avec quelques contusions et
j'ai vu un élément peut il est tombé
dans un autre morceau que tomber
derrière c'est impressionnant ah bah oui
alors sur côté je suis allé au bord de
la charente avant et côté rochereuil
avait la grosse fumée noire qui sortait
des débris éparpillés sur un rayon de 2
km un élément de l'arrière de l'appareil
est tombé sur une maison qui a aussitôt
pris feu ces deux occupantes sont
légèrement brûlé ont travaillé toute ma
vie pour avoir une petite maison la
pièce 76 ans c'est inimaginable
j'ai vu le parti perd corps est là c'est
qu'elle s'est crashé devant là bas et
que des femmes qui faisait aussi aux
thésards une enquête est ouverte
l'appareil de type priseur appartenait à
la base aéronavale de landivisiau dans
le finistère
il participait à une manoeuvre
d'interception prévu au dessus de
l'océan après l'explosion son pilote a
pu le diriger vers une zone marécageuse
évitant est ce un centre commercial à
tokyo le patron de la police
personnellement chargé de l'enquêté sur
l'attentât au gaz mortel commis la
semaine dernière dans le métro a été
grièvement blessé ce matin au moment où
il sortait de son domicile
son agresseur a réussi à prendre la
fuite à jérusalem une vingtaine d'
extrémistes israéliens arrêtés par la
police ils étaient venus prier sur
l'esplanade des mosquées est réservé aux
musulmans dans les territoires autonomes
palestiniens et notamment dans la bande
de gaza la police mise en place par
yasser arafat éprouve encore des
difficultés à faire régner l'ordre et
notamment la circulation témoignages
haut en couleurs de notre correspondant
charles enderlin
quand le policier fait comme ça il faut
s'arrêter après des années l'intifada
les conducteurs de gazar et apprennent
le respect du code de la route en arabe
contredanses ceux des bras là c'est la
première fois que des palestiniens
reçoit des pv dressés par un policier
lui aussi palestiniens mais curieusement
l'aspect historique de l'événement ne
semble pas enthousiasmer les conducteurs
moi je dois veiller à la circulation ici
les bonnes paroles les avertissements ça
ne sert à rien par contre les pv
ça aide quand j'en mets ça roule ils
discutent toujours le public s'en mêle
mais je ne cède pas l'atmosphère c'est
chaud et ce monsieur tient absolument à
s'adresser à la télévision française
on est miss chauffeurs de taxis
autorisés à gaza et bien qu on paie nos
impôts
on n'a pas ou le gars et on ramasse les
voyageurs ici et ils nous collent des pv
mais voici que les policiers découvrent
que la circulation est bloquée ce
conducteur d'autobus a décidé de
participer à la discussion
à part le problème du parking on n'a
rien contre la police
elle fait des efforts pourvu qu'elle
réussisse depuis la mise en place de
l'autonomie en juin de l'année dernière
il y a eu mille accidents de voitures à
gaz à quillan et 57 morts et plus de 800
blessés déjà l'action de la police
palestinienne après s'en tenir
selon ces statistiques le nombre
d'accidents est en baisse
manque de chance pour ce conducteur il
est tombé sur un des chefs de la police
au moment où il roulait en sens interdit
sans le moindre papier d'identité les
conduits au poste sous bonne escorte
le délinquant va s'en tirer avec une
forte amende en cette période de chômage
des autorités somaliennes
la france devrait bientôt offrir 22 feu
rouge à la ville de gaza et ses
policiers auront pour tâche d'apprendre
à tous à les respecter même à ceux qui
ignorent ouvertement les lois de la
route
on va gagner faites ce que vous voulez
on va gagner voilà une dernière image
avant de laisser la place à carnet de
campagne la première conférence de
presse du boxeur américain mike tyson
est sorti de prison
samedi dernier l'ancien champion du
monde des poids lourds annoncé qu'il
reprendrait sa carrière sur les rings et
qu'il conservera vraisemblablement comme
manager le célèbre john king voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal plus court que
d'habitude pour laisser la place donc à
carnet de campagne autour de daniel
bilalian la rédaction reçoit ce soir le
socialiste bernard kouchner je souhaite
une très bonne soirée